- [Man] But my real question is
everybody's really talking about
how Twitter's in trouble.
Could Twitter become MySpace?
- Yes.
- [Man] Ooh. That's scary.
- For Twitter.
- [Man] Well, it's
scary for me too.
I've gotten used to getting
my news from Twitter.
- Great, people used to get
their news from the radio.
- [Man] Facts. Fact.
- Right? I was used to getting
my music from MTV.
- [Man] So we just
got to realign and
get our news from
Snapchat or Instagram?
- Yep.
- [Man] Okay.
Twitter's in trouble. Shit.
- And by the way, Twitter is
reason I'm even sitting here.
As you know, Twitter was the
first time I really popped.
Back in the day
I was doing my wine show,
I jumped on Twitter.
I thought it was
going to be big.
It ended up being way bigger
and I really popped and
transitioned into business
content instead of wine content
and so I love Twitter.
Twitter's like the first girl
I ever hooked up with.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
There's always that
piece in my soul.
And so it makes,
it's hard for me to say that.
By the way, I sit on
a lot of Twitter stock.
I sold a lot of it but I still
have a lot and a lot of
economics--
- [Man] What can it do?
- They got to change.
You got to evolve.
Madonna did it right.
She reinvented herself 14 times.
That's why she
had a long career.
You got to reinvent yourself.
Twitter didn't make product
changes for six years
in it's prime.
- [Man] Yeah.
- So let's talk about sports.
When you're the best athlete
and you're like the guy
and you're like on of
the top 15 players,
basketball, I'm looking at Dunk,
@Dunk on Instagram,
give you some love,
he's got one of the
big basketball accounts
so I'm thinking about that.
I think about basketball
players, Draymond Green.
He's my buddy.
Draymond really worked on his
game every offseason.
Ricky Rubio, the flashy point
guard from Minnesota,
if he developed
his outside shot,
he would have been
a much bigger player.
He had all the passing skills,
the quickness,
he's got everything
if instead of going
to a Ibiza and
fucking chicks
in the offseason
he worked on his 18-foot jumper,
he'd be in the game.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Twitter was banging chicks
in the summer, got it?
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
(hip hop music)